do you think a peer group holds you back
or helped you like as far as suppose you
have a big circle of friends you know
you talked about being more alone when
you were younger do you think as you get
into your adult years that's really a
bad thing in some ways because sometimes
if you mean like friends within the
industry or do you mean like for like
just friends period friends period do
you think sometimes that helps what you
think it holds you back because you only
you don't want to rise above them you
want to just stay where they are and if
maybe they aren't doing anything you'll
stay at that level but if they are
you'll want to go with them that makes
sense does a peer group help you rise or
can it also hold you back I think if you
are like working together but like I
don't have like friends at us hang out
with him pretty much a loner you know
and then the people i do hang out with
other people in the industry and and
what i think is important I was actually
think about this earlier so it's funny
guest is um I think it's good to grow a
family I think it's one reason it's been
hard for me because I'm always out on my
own you know and if I work with people
us and I'm since this new PS whoever is
free at the moment but I think if you
had maybe 10 people who all work
together like look at the mumblecore
movement you know how they all kind of
you know like got big and they all had
you know kind of work you know exchanged
working on films together or look at
like James Franco and Seth Rogen all you
know they all ended say oh they all got
each other's back and they're stronger
that way you know and you know even with
the the coming back of Stallone and all
these people you know like they all they
all have each other's back and unless
you're like Tom Cruise you know like I
was in say or Denzel Washington even him
like do you notice once him Tony Scott
started working together it was like
every movie almost you know and I I
think would be great to have something
like that because I think
kind of if you're if you're doing well
together you know just keep feeding off
of it and keep you know it's like you
know all the few of them to you lift me
up it's like you're doing it by yourself
it's just um you know you just climb in
a ladder you get exhausted but if you
got you know friends carrying you okay
you're tired let me help you up in your
tire let me help you about you know it's
like you to break and you know I mean
like I think that's what's important it
would be great to have friends within
the industry to create a family really I
think it's really good when you create a
family like I worked with this one actor
Kevin gauge and I've been talking to him
for like seven years but I just never
had gotten a chance like do anything
with them or even meet up with him it
was a you know phone call and the emails
for seven years and then finally we
worked on something together and he was
just like the best person world to work
with he's always like a bad guy I can
heat and all these movies he's known for
being this horrendous kind of sleazy
sleazy bad guy on top of that but he
sits like just you feel so motivated
working with them and so like as soon as
I worked with him it was like I worked
on like five films with them and like a
six month period because I just wanted
to keep working with them and that
definitely made me want it because I
wanted to keep working with him that
maybe you want to keep working you know
and and it's like I would love to work
on anything he's working on because he's
just so awesome to be around and I think
if you had like 10 people like that even
if you just had you know one other
person like that it's just I think that
that helps you know so hopefully that a
specific question it would be great to
have people like that i think but in
real life i don't really have like I
don't go after Adam it's hard for me cuz
I don't drink I don't do drugs and I
realize it actually creates a lot of
problems having a social life because
the ATM came up yesterday the drinking
thing comes up all the time people don't
know what to do with me because I don't
drink as if there's nothing else to do
in life or something I don't know and so
I just kind of I'm just kind of a loner
and I'm always working on movies and so
in my free time I'm either watching
movies or I just hang out the dogs like
I go to the gym you know so I'm pretty
much a loner
you